hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with shofu what's going on
guys and we're here with it summer of
arcade and we're playing continues move
into turkeys out of the darkness out of
the dark shadows out of the shadows out
of the shadows of darkness anyway
welcome ok mode and we decided to pick
our character okay well I'm gonna play
Donatello
yeah obviously Dontos the best but
Leonardo is pretty close it's for a
while longer
confirmed turtle selection hell yeah now
that's more like it
I'm the main character I'm the best main
character the red ones the leader though
it was really sad fan arts of teenage me
into his turtle for it painted each one
as the last surviving member did you
ever see that not nervous so sad it was
like Donatello was holding all the color
bands of the air every other one anyway
go back into the game that's the combos
the cop now you sit down you don't get
you'd think that slashing him with
katanas would be a bit more damaging
yeah but I'm doing equal damage with a
stick is that pick up a bull or is that
just a blob get its kind of just rocking
back and forth over there
oh no it's a feature not a bug okay
let's go oh you can run or I can throw
ninja stars oh wow Suda good can I throw
[ __ ] neurocircuits
can I do any of those things pretty soon
no I'm just gonna swing mystic you know
I need fancy moves anything like that I
got just whack him in the face with its
big all I got over that face in the face
yeah what I'm too nice I think somehow I
still have more points than you so I
think I'm winning here it's been that
way since the beginning I don't know
exactly I think that just shows oh maybe
I should stop hitting just one what did
I just do it was awesome
okay whatever so there's multiple combos
that you can do well I wish every I'm
behind a dumpster right now but that is
not me maybe you should bring him over
here
I don't know and now I'm fighting
someone off camera over here it's so
epic it can't be shown on TV or you guys
saw oh wait no there's no in there we
got a fight okay let's continue on oh my
god the name of the game came out of the
wait it was out of the darkness shadows
out of the shadows darkness where
shadows come from darkness and then
Donatello goes to get some
or something like that sounds like a
plan yeah I mean this was supposed to be
a way back then it was the most
realistic similar did you ever get that
boy where he was like the truck from
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles to the van
that shot pizzas out of the back end of
it oh I remember that one
I remember yeah yeah I mean that was a
deprived child honest clearly who didn't
want to run around their house shooting
pizzas okay I can't how do you run the
right bumper oh I should know that
because I have run they have spikes
printed tags it's like a car Lou oh I
think I'm gonna distinct advantage for
points because my stick seems to hit a
lot of people all over the place yeah
like especially in the ball he did
closing up on me on points hey I'm
trying to give you the benefit of the
doubt here Oh pizza oh you didn't even
share it I was hungry too
doesn't mean you get to scarf it for
yourself much whatever Wow we're gonna
talk about this later
whoa what the ah this is a guy whose
name I care never see davinci wait what
does he have in his hand what is it I
have now the guy that you're beating up
right now oh that's a giant monkey
wrench you just change characters yes I
did you didn't see that where I just
kind of morphed into it never mind how
did I die and then the other one came to
take my place oh look I gotta be I gotta
be the best guy well if you two shared
the damn pizza I wouldn't be there right
now thank you very much
whatever whatever were like brothers
okay all right whoo there's another club
that's just sticking straight up out of
the ground
this know that Peter meter is kind of
hiding clear okay here we go
okay there we go
so is there an end goal to this game I'm
not sure this this is just arcade
oh there we go awesome well have we do
that but do it again
oh you can't on with the directional pad
with your britches why why is that a
thing we get a demoralize the enemy by
high-five oh look at the points at home
I'm right next is because I died
probably maybe I don't know whatever
this is I wanted okay my green bar is
glowing what does that mean well good
for you is there probably still enemies
driving this kiplyn home with your
weapons they were like sticking out of
your back I'm getting my ass handed to
me here oh oh you're doing fantastic I'm
doing horribly because I'm not down to
teller I've got these stupid short ring
piece of crap and dagger things what
what did these things go I don't even
know that's amore dama see I'd rather
just pick up that monkey right on the
ground and start swinging it around I do
more damage anyway
you know another thing that everyone's
good about the kitchen why wouldn't the
enemies just pick up a gun all right
because as far as I know the Ninja
Turtles never ever ever ever
they're always melee and I mean that's
cool Don makes for a great show and I'm
not gonna question that logically from
the enemy's standpoint I mean guns
aren't even that expensive they have
money for all these monkey wrenches and
baseball I would have won that what
except look I got a I see even if with
my thousand points added on I wouldn't
want that no because I'm Leonardo
somebody tell this man I'm not you
whatever play the campaign unlock the
next level well I guess they'll ban this
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles attack from
the darkness of shadows stinky food
reward summer arcade Thank You shofu
Thank You mr. Mike thank you everybody
for watching goodbye forever
bye
I didn't actually mean to recorder me
how can I be a chicken with my hippo